Rick shot-caller explores the cost of
trying to survive in prison and if we
look at everything in life everything
has a price sometimes it's just time
versus money what are the costs of being
a screenwriter I realize the stakes
aren't as high as as being in the prison
system but what are the costs of being a
screenwriter
hopefully the cost of me being a
screenwriter at least for me is being
authentic you know so the movies that I
try to portray is I do I want entertain
you heck yeah I want you to if you're
going to pay money to sit in a seat and
watch my movie I want you to be
entertained I want you to be thrilled
but I also hope that you're getting
something out of it to where that it's
not so much about the message of the
movie but it makes you think about it it
makes you think about your own life and
and see the movie in a way that feels
like it's so grounded in authentic that
this could be us navigating this world
and this world is very real what we're
seeing so to me that's probably the
scariest part is all three of my movies
felon you know snitch and then
shot-caller the first people that I
showed this to were law enforcement and
gang members because their lives or dies
their right this is either authentic to
them saying yeah I know that these three
stories are fiction
well snitch is a true story but if you
look at these three things and saying
yeah most of these characters in the
world is fictional but it's a hundred
percent accurate of what this is this is
our world this is what we live every
single day so that's the type of
validation I'm looking for for the
stories that I tell in terms of them
screenplay structure is there a certain
format that you follow when you start
writing yeah I don't I don't follow
format I think that for me I think that
it takes a lot of screenwriters now and
I think a lot of filmmakers are getting
too caught up in the structure of things
and I like to kind of mess that up I
like to like to be unconventional and I
like to just try to think if I'm sitting
watching this movie am i if I moved
forward at every single moment am i
learning something new am i sucked into
this world whether the first act rate
came at page 30 or 70 whatever it may be
it's this the thing that propels itself
and moves it forward so for me it's
about storytelling first
and four million structure a second so
there's not certain because you're
trying to hit at certain points yeah I
think you know when you've written as
many things as I've written at this
point in my life it all kind of kind of
comes intuitive you know your first
instinctive you know you know where
these things are going to be you know
that you want people to know kind of
where this movie's gonna go in the first
10 minutes so it's not meandering and
you're sitting in the theater going for
30 minutes going god what the hell this
movie's going to be about so yeah there
are certain bullet points that I'm fine
some that I'm trying to hit throughout
it but at this point it's just become
extinct extinct 'iv to just good
storytelling at least I hope it that's
why you know that's what I bets my
intentions are okay so this is your
fourth script shot-caller is that right
fourth no I've written countless
countless others okay so but in that
since 2001 you've been writing or
earlier yes about that okay yeah um so
then how many scripts total would you
say you've written even shorts even
things that are in a drawer that no one
will ever see um between all the studio
movies and stuff that written and
scripts on over 50 over 50 oh yeah as
far as like jobs
yeah like things that were either
produced or were paid for you know
developed well I'm in this in the system
at least over 50 over 50 okay so your
process for writing shot-caller I know
you had I guess gone with it as a prison
volunteer I actually became a volunteer
of with the California Department of
Corrections working with parole to where
could give me an unflinching look at the
prison system without somebody knowing I
was a filmmaker and then trying to be
biased or protective or holding back I
got candid look at the prison system
inside out
you